hello everyone and welcome to pi data
hamburg
meetup
we are very happy to have you here with
us
and
just before we get started and just in
case you know uh we are going to record
this meetup and in case you wouldn't
like to have your name your voice on the
internet
just be mindful of uh renaming yourself
also if you prefer not to ask questions
live you can just write them on chat
whatever feels best uh for you
if you have any questions as i said
sometimes people a little bit shy they
don't like to ask questions live you can
just raise your hand and we are going to
unmute you that's option one option two
is just you raise your hand or you just
write on the check whatever suits you
uh and this is by data hamburg so just
in case the 58 is a global community for
developers and users of open source data
tools
and pydate is an educational program of
num focus a non-profit organization in
the u.s
and i would like just to share here uh
our social media so if you would like
just you know to share a little bit how
it was your experience at this meetup if
you would like to follow us the video of
this meetup is going to be available
later on
uh at pi data youtube channel we're also
going to share a link with you later on
for it
and this is a little bit about pi data
hamburg team so we have here obinna
who's going to say hi
hi
hi
that's a short hi we have alexandrus
hello guys
that finish is not here with us katie
she's joining us a little bit later and
myself my name is camila
so your host for tonight's meetup
i'm going to host it together with
obinna and with katie
and just in case
we like to have people from everywhere
in the world with us giving a talk so in
case you feel like you would like to
give a talk about anything you are
building regarding open source data
tools uh especially if you're a first
time speaker and you would like to
be with us and give a talk just reach
out to us either on our social media
channels or just to any of the
organizers would be very happy to have
you with us could be that you have to
wait a little bit we really give a
priority to have um
diverse present in everything that we do
at pi data hamburg so we try to balance
our lineup and give opportunities to
everyone as much as possible so just get
in touch and you try to place in one of
our meetups and of course you're always
looking for volunteers so if you would
like to help uh with meetup planning
trying to find me even if you're not a
volunteer but you have a nice speaker to
recommend just do it we would be very
happy with that
so this is just a little bit of our
agenda for today so we have now next
hosanna giving her talk we are going to
have a break around 7 45
then we have alwa what doing with us at
uh 7 55 and then around 8 40 you're
going to having an open discussion and
networking
so
i would like now to hand over to josana
jolivera gomez she's a senior data
scientist at huawei's telecon she's also
the team leader at ai wonder girls and
she's going to give the talk atina arta
system women in ai creations
thank you camila let me just go ahead
and share my screen
can you guys confirm you can see my
screen
as we can see it
okay perfect
so
yeah uh cool nice introduction and uh
thank you guys for for being here today
so uh today i'm gonna talk a little bit
about the projects that uh
i've been uh carrying out uh with my
team the ai on undergrowth
and uh this is a
talk a little bit about ai and art which
can be something that is very
interesting if you've never seen that
before and the nice thing about this
talk is also that is um this is an
initiative that we started for a
hackathon that is this is the
sai hackathon
um
and this was uh something that was
hosted uh in hamburg itself so it's
quite nice and the work that we built is
something that is open source so at the
end i will also show how you can also
contribute as well
so
just to get started a little bit about
the ai wonder girls
so um we are a team of ladies working on
ai projects
on social impact
uh we've been working on several
projects about ai for healthcare but we
also
participated in other projects on other
stuff as
ai and art as i'm going to talk about
today
and uh we are pretty much like um
friends of friends so we've been meeting
each other on all those ai communities
that we find out there
we started with volunteering and then
you know like we just keep coming back
to the volunteering and we meet the same
people and eventually we become friends
so we never met each other in person but
we've been uh friends for uh almost a
year now
and uh the eye on the ghost thing is
actually a thing that is
always changing so we have this group of
ladies some of them are actually here
tonight and um
every time that we decided to go for
hackathon we just decided was gonna was
gonna be part of the the new version of
our team so that's uh one important
thing to say
um
and yeah and in the past year we've been
uh participating many projects and uh we
also won a couple of hackathons and uh
though like of course participating
projects normally about the competition
and winning i think there is something
very nice uh to be said about the whole
team of women uh winning uh hackathons
um
because we still are so few in this
field so it's like in the field of ai
and tech we still have like uh 10 to 15
percent of women and let alone like uh
um
more senior positions and so on so i
think it's something that is very nice
to also inspire all the women
and uh other like young people out there
who are interested in these fields to
just show them that it's possible
so
we've been doing uh quite a lot of stuff
as i mentioned like how we've been
working on um
yeah for healthcare because it's
something that
quite a few of us are interested about
um but you also worked on some other
projects some of them for hackathons
some of them were just because we like
it so we just decided to organize some
stuff so for example we've been working
on projects about for example natural
disasters about forecasting of
earthquakes or projects about the
climate change so this is something that
i'm going to be giving a talk in a
couple of weeks i can also share with
you the link of our presentation
and uh especially today i'm going to
talk a little bit about the work that
i've been doing in terms of ai and art
and this is something that we've been
quite fascinated since the i think end
of last year or beginning of this year
we started to have conversations about
it and then eventually this uh became uh
first of all an article the beginning of
this year this is something that we
published i think it was in january or
february
and um
so this is something that we published
um
under
the ondena community so this is a
community for uh ai for social impact
and um
and because of this this article we
actually started to become more
interested in the topics of ai and how
can we perceive ai
uh as a source of creation as well
because most of the time when we're
talking about ai or data sciences when
we're trying to build tools we're trying
to build something that is like very
applied and so on and there is usually
some
application in society and that's all
very important of course
but we don't really see necessarily ais
and something like um
as a sort of creation and when we talk
about um
ai and art i think there's a lot to be
said in terms of um like creativity
that we tend to see art as pretty much
like um
something that comes from the minds of
humans and this has been the case for
many years
but now we have the opportunity to
actually use
this technology
to
both use it as a tool such as for
example as we have many other
technologies for example we have
computers that are used for you know
internal design or something like that
but uh we can also use it as a sort of
uh source sort of creativity as well so
for example here i'm just uh showing you
like uh that we can use ai for example
for
uh reconstructing
uh places that uh are like are now
ruined and so on so like whatever
someone's saying is from italy so this
is a place that has like lots of like
beautiful places and so on so like it's
difficult for historians to actually
reconstruct and understand the
architecture of the past so it's
something that uh yeah i can help with
we uh also like there is this modern art
so to say like like applications that
are more straightforward associations
for example architecture
and decoration and so on
but uh ai can also be used for like um
really creating new ideas or like uh not
necessarily creative like uh augmenting
new ideas in the sense of like you can
combine the work of several artists
and uh which in a way is what we do as
humans
well we are all inspired by things and
then in a way like we have a machine
there is also inspired by the work of of
artists and then it creates itself its
own mixture of that and this is for
example what we see here this is um a
portrait it's called a portrait of
edmond bellamy
and this is something that was not
created by
a human being this was created by
um
a machine which was created by an ai uh
specifically using this technology of
guns you guys might be familiar there is
basically this uh fake technology that
we have nowadays
but it's also nice to show uh that um
this can be uh like the same
technologies that sometimes we hear or
we we are concerned about like uh
ethical topics and so on which is very
very fair and we should be but this can
also be used for something that is very
inspiring such as for example creating
uh a new paintings that uh are like how
for example how can you say who is the
author of the painting and so on so this
is something that is quite interesting
um and if you are more interested about
other applications you can have a look
into our article
um
[Music]
other possibilities of using ai
for art is of course uh
this idea of bringing artists back uh to
life
so one um initiative that i always like
to share because it's like something
that i i find it really fascinating i
was like
again this idea of deep fake uh and uh
this is the museum from um
[Music]
the museum from delhi uh in in florida
so i think there's someone place in
florida so this is something if you want
to check it out
um i don't know if it's still open right
now but uh this is a uh as an exhibition
that is called the the lead lives
and the idea is that uh because there
are so many recordings uh from the uh
from the lee and there are so many
information of him moving and so on so
it was possible to recreate him and make
the
visitors of the museum to interact with
him so here you can see that there's a
if you go to their website it's really
cool like you can see the people coming
and he greets them and he talks to them
he even takes a selfie with them
and uh explains a little bit about some
of the the visit of the museum and this
is something that is fascinating
um there are of course like other
applications of ai such as for example
for for books i don't know if you guys
heard of that but for example there is
this creation that uh ai
learns from the chapters from harry
potter
and then creates a new chapter so this
is something that came out a couple of
years ago
and this is a little bit about what i'm
going to be sharing today as well
and uh also like uh extracting uh the
style of a painting or a style of an
artist and transferring this into other
um images and this is something that i
think you guys are quite familiar uh
nowadays there are many of those filters
and so on and uh probably if you've been
to one of those
of those um
uh
exhibitions from one goal where you
probably had the chance to have a
picture uh with the starry night style
as we have here for mona lisa
and uh
and this is something that is like a
quite fascinating this is the idea that
we can use technology to
creation and not only like for
necessarily applications i mean it's
also application but something that is a
bit more
uh in the
creative side
um
so uh in this context uh we were quite
excited about doing something about arts
specifically
and uh then uh this later
i kind of more like the middle of this
year came up with this um
super
artistic ai hackathon this is a saai so
it's the super artistic ai factory
uh this is a hackathon that was hosted
by the woods art
institute in hamburg
and the idea here was to bring together
uh exactly this um augmentation of art
so like
take on
artists uh take tech experts take uh
designers take like people from with
very different backgrounds
and putting them together
and exploring
what is it that we can build with ai
and uh for this we had our team here so
this is like a this version of the ion
girls is like i call the ai one the
girls v5
because before that there were other
four teams
and uh specifically for this project we
created uh this open source initiative
like this is a prototype and something
that is still under construction uh that
is called the athena art assistant
and this is a little bit where i'm gonna
be talking in the next part of the talk
but uh here you can see that the the
girls like uh we are very good friends
and like i mean we've worked quite a lot
and have the last
months together so um it's very nice
because we are all spread all over the
world and we still managed to find time
and the time zones and so on to just get
together and then just to build
something together
so um
the inspiration for this project uh we
thought okay we want to do something
with ai and art
but
we are also like a group of ladies and
we also always try to
uh find something that is not just an
application but it has like some
something
that has this social impact context and
for us when we were looking into this
idea of ai and art and so on we came
across
this topic
that very similar to the ai world or the
tech world
we have not so many women uh in the
we have so many women in the tech world
and uh we do have a lot of women is
about 50 50 in the arts world
however uh when we have um the promotion
of the work or the promotion of the
artist's autistic world work
of women this is really
really low um and like for example you
can see that the majority of the work
that is promoted in
exhibitions and so on is the work of
males and is also the work of uh white
people
so uh we fought i mean this is
specifically for the us but uh the idea
is that this is more or less the same
all over the world maybe with different
numbers but it's
it is a problem it's a problem of
representativity there is basically also
a problem that we have in the data
science or ai field as well
and then we thought uh how can we build
something
that can be uh an application that pro
helps to promote the work of women
artists
so um and then our idea was like can we
build something that is an ai creation
so that has this augmentation has this
this kind of like a very interesting
aspect of like a connecting uh ai and
and creativity uh but that is also
helping uh promoting the work of women
artists and that is also implemented all
by women so this is basically uh was our
idea so we thought like can we create
something can we create an ai or several
ais in this case
that can um
be inspired by the work of females
and
basically that the data that comes into
those models
is the the artistic world of females
work of females and that is implemented
by a group of women
and there is um
indians something that is like the
connection between ai and females work
uh artistic world work specifically
so that's uh the idea for the uh athena
art assistant so we thought like okay we
have to build a prototype we have only a
couple of weeks so um let's just try to
uh go with the easy thing um and the
easy thing like for us like we have this
kind of like this this style now or for
some time that whenever we are building
something we built like um
many of many we're gonna say many
applications of ai
for one topic so we did this before with
healthcare we built like lots of
applications into one product and i
thought like oh can we do something like
this with ai for arts
and our idea was to create an assistant
that can look into different kinds of
art so for example here we have cinema
we have paintings we have animations and
we have poetry
and can we uh
build one one application that can take
care of all of that um can help with
this thing of like um
empowering or women artists and being
inspired by the work of women artists
and so on so what we built was a data
stream centric
site a data centric approach so the idea
is basically that we take the data
uh we take like a solution that already
exists out there so we don't need to
reinvent the wheel because we didn't
have so much time for preparing for the
hackathon because it's always very busy
and so on so we take uh
things that already exist out there
uh applied for those
those topics within the arts world
like cinema paintings and so on
and uh we try to bring a data centric
perspective uh in a way that is like uh
we just uh change the data sets we use
the same
methods and so on
but we change the data sets and we see
what comes out of out of that and that
was our idea so basically what we did
for this prototype was to create uh
fortifications um the first one is uh
maybe you guys are familiar with that or
not uh there is this uh very typical
problem when you're learning data
science and so on this is a little bit
more like uh
intermediate or advanced but uh that you
can create recommended systems based on
um
some data sets that are out there and so
on the imdb data set from uh kaggle was
very common and our idea was to just
take the data set
find
the
movies that were
generated by
female directors
and see what you get out of that
uh same with uh other other applications
so for example as creating poetry same
idea as we did with
as was done for example with the harry
potter book of learning from the text of
the harry potter we did for uh poetry so
can we take a poetry only for female or
in this case only for male and
non-binary transgender groups like
minorities and uh creative poetry of
course based on some topics and so on
and see what we get out of that
uh we did the same for a style transfer
like um this idea of just for example
people usually do this thing of taking
van gogh's style and putting into
something or put into our pictures or
taking mona lisa style and so on so what
happens if we do the opposite if we take
those classic images and we transform
those into the style of the women
artists
work as well so we did this using the
smithsonian um
women
artist
open source data
and finally the last one i'm going to
show you is like how to use um
a technology that's called
text to image
that
to create animations to create images
from from feminist quotes
and then with that we create an
animation so that's basically what i'm
going to show you right now
so uh just to give you an idea of how we
had to go through it of course like we
had to spend some time brainstorming on
how we're going to build this and so on
and this is something that is still in
progress then we had to collect the data
and uh spend a very long time relabeling
things because uh it's very impressive
how difficult it is to find a data out
there that is
uh labeled in terms of gender especially
nuts so this is something that we had to
do like we had to relabel a lot of stuff
and then of course we had to apply those
models this was the easier part because
we were just using something that
already exists so we're just taking
notebooks from out there that already
exist
and
using that to finally deploy it so the
requirement of our uh results is
something that is still not completely
uh done we did for some parts and you're
still working on it and
if anyone wants to participate in this
is something that is you're very welcome
to
join us in this initiative
so uh just for the movies to give you an
idea like i don't know if everyone is
familiar with the imdb website but um
the idea is basically it's a website
where you have um
i don't know entertainment usually like
movies or tv shows uh information you
have a description of the of the show or
the movie
you have like uh people that can rate
whether they like it or not and um has
of course like uh many other information
trailers and so on the images and the
cast who participated and of course also
has the directors
so what we did over here was ready to
take this the data set
that has uh this amount of uh
about 85 or 86 000 uh movies
and almost 35 000 directors
and then we said like let's filter out
all the
males are at least like a filter uh to
have only the
the movies that the directors at least
one of the directors uh is is a is a
woman and that's something that we did
uh that was uh possible to do because we
already had some information out there
like it was not something super simple
but uh this is part of the work one of
our colleagues
and uh then what we did was to just uh
use uh some
uh already available of their codes for
doing the recommendation system the
recommendation system is basically
something that if you watch netflix or
amazon or something of that sort you're
familiar with um you watch something
there is a thing that everybody is
watching so for example now everybody is
watching the eternals or something on
cinema and that is something that's
going to be recommended to you
but then now what what if we only
recommend to use stuff for there is
or stuff not sorry movies that are uh
generated or directed by women and then
it's something that is a little bit uh
like uh
uh subtle if you want
but uh you know like the amount of
stuff that we consume
that is uh only generated by like
um
in a way like a majority of like people
that have this their work promoted and
all the others don't
so we could do that uh and then finding
like uh of course like here we selected
also like in terms of gender and so on
so here for example it's like a movies
uh
in the sense of romance
uh we we had some sort of like a
waiting rate so it's not just like a
homemade how much they were voted or how
popular they were is a formula that we
used for that
well to to see how
it's popular and how much like the
people like it so um and from that we
can
recommend movies that are
generated by
women directors
and the other way of doing that is
analyzing the how similar
the contact the content of the
description of a movie is from some
other movie so let's say that you like
uh lost in translation i know if you
guys know this movie this movie is
actually quite cool and um and you want
to see like oh i like this movie and i
would like to see a movie that is kind
of the same style at least in the
description
and um
but it's there is directed by a woman so
you can uh look into this and then here
you have a list of those movies from of
course the list from amd and so on so
it's something that uh it's not
necessarily uh the whole
list of movies in the world and so on
but uh this is a fairly huge uh updated
uh set so it's something that uh you can
probably watch lots of movies
directed by women uh just by looking
into this
so this is something that uh we did like
to promote the work of women artists of
course we can expand this for example to
music and so on like first we would have
to look into some other data sets but
that's uh an idea that is very um simple
so to say because then you can promote
other groups and for example the same
can be done for uh for doesn't need to
be only women can be maybe for example i
don't know latin american uh women or
can be you know like um
other sorts of things that you can do
but it's a data-centric approach so we
are using the same codes that already
exist out there we are just changing the
data and see what we get up there
so this was the first application the
second one is the poetry
so again we did the same thing we took
a data set that is open source uh from
the poetry foundation
we had 13.8 uh a thousand points over
there
um
i didn't tag all this uh data set this
is huge but i tagged like around uh half
of it
and uh the idea was to find like i had
to look into the names and
images into the descriptions of the
authors
the poets and see
which ones are female which ones are
non-binary which ones are transgender of
course um you can only find non-binary
and transgender if it's stated in their
description otherwise you don't know
um and then of course you have to
pre-process the text and like uh clean
the data and so on
um but the idea here was to take this um
the the list of those poets
uh filter out uh the males
get the female non-binary and
transgender
uh filter in terms of uh some topic uh
so for example i chose the
lgbtq
uh topic this topic actually didn't have
so much uh poetry so like here is
something that was done only with 25
points so it's not super perfect
but the idea was again to learn uh uh
from those poems uh under those topics
so the the topic of the appointment was
itself uh under the lgbtq uh topic
and then uh see what you find and then
here i have just an example
so what we did was to create a uh and uh
long short term memory model
um with those um
kinds of authors and uh based on a prime
word you have to give the initial word
that you want and also the length of the
your poem so this is something that we
did over here
and that's the poetry that you got of
course like we did this for many other
initial words and uh sometimes it
doesn't make much sense of course
because it's something that is like um
especially for this data set it was only
25 uh poems but some other topics that
are maybe more common you find much more
but this is still nice because you can
still see this uh if you read
the the text and so on you can
see this kind of like
it understands uh
the
concept of the poetry
so the things uh rhyme and they they
have like this nice um
it it feels like poetry so as i said
like not always uh for this uh dating
such and so on but it's something that
is
nice and can be expanded of course to
other topics we had also the topic of
race and ethics
ethnic sorry uh so it's something that
is quite nice and the idea is to also
expand this and keep tagging the data
and maybe include other languages as
well so this is something that is quite
exciting
uh in the yeah that was it about poetry
uh then um
for painting
we used uh the as i said before the
smithsonian american women artists
um data set
so what we did was to look into open
source um
art
images so this is for visual arts
so if you look into their website you
can see that there is a very long list
of artists over there there are more if
you keep scrolling
no this is just an example
and our idea here was to do the same
thing that i was showing before with
taking the style of i don't know starry
night or something like that and just
transforming this into some other
painting
and the things that usually people just
don't look into the style of
the work of other artists because there
are the super famous uh paintings and so
on and then why would they you know like
uh so the idea is that yeah they should
so that's what we're showing here so
this is one of the things that was
actually deployed by our police so
idea here is to take the mona lisa
uh input image
so this is the image that is going to be
changed to have the style of some other
image
and then the image that we are choosing
to have the style that is the the the
content if you want or sorry the style
that you want
this is uh the self portrait from mary
kasich and this is an american uh
painter and uh of course this data
status is still like for american women
or artists so we can of course try to
look into other data
but uh it's nice because you can see
that you can uh you can have this you
can generate several of those depending
on how you tune your model or someone
but it's quite interesting because um
you can generate things that are
actually quite artistic
and uh you get to play around with like
um
for example you can see that this uh
style of colors or even this like a
texture that uh is very typical from
this artist uh can be transferred into
something else and it's exactly the idea
of style transfer
and in a way uh if you want is like this
idea like let's say i really like this
uh artist and i also really like um
these other artists here as well and
then if i am a painter and i want to you
know like be inspired by both i probably
would do something between so or maybe
something else but that's the idea of of
using this application over here and of
course we have we did this for many
other i think around 10 other paintings
here is just something that i just
finding is very interesting like this
image here but there are many others
there you can also have a look later on
um
[Music]
and then the last one i'm going to show
you is the
animation
and i don't know if you guys
are familiar with what happened at the
beginning of last year the end of last
year i don't remember
um there was uh this new technology that
came from open ai that is uh that um
some models now some um
language models now are so
um how can i say advanced
that they can really learn of course
from a massive uh amount of data
uh what uh uh what a word means in terms
of an image so for example as much as we
humans or a child and understand that if
i say bottle
you can imagine a borrow if you say
elephant you can imagine another country
and so on and then uh there are now
those technologies uh developed by open
ai uh there is the berlin that can also
can also do that and the beginning of
this year i think or in the last year
there was this uh there was this whole
thing about the avocado chair that i
don't know if you guys saw it but that's
basically the result of the output of
this model if you try to uh you know
like um apply um image um sorry text to
image
uh
and uh using the input of avocado so we
thought
uh what if we uh in this case not train
the model but if we use the already
trained model
to
uh some uh feminist codes like we tried
some some short ones and we generate a
couple of images as much as we say
avocado chair and then we have lots of
those here
what if we take some feminist quote and
we just try to create a couple of images
of those and what if we put it in a
video and uh and then make a maybe put
some music on there and then this is an
animation and then we can see a feminist
quote from a perspective of an ai
in a video
that's basically what we did over here
i'll just show you one example i think
now
is the moment
that
i don't know if my
um
i just don't know if my microphone will
work let me see if i can change the
settings
okay so you are you should be able to
hear me
[Music]
can you hear the music
yes we can
[Music]
okay so just with my headphones again
so
this was a
short um
video we have some others that are
longer the music here of course is not
uh ai based so it's something that we
can in the future expand to maybe also
have music generated by either is also
playing the video
so for now it's only part of it that is
created by ai but the idea is to just
explore how we can um kind of this
combination of
human ideas and uh
ai um
also like creations in a mixture and
this is art as well or at least we can
perceive it as as artists or something
creative
um
with that uh also about that
uh i'll just
[Music]
tell you a little bit of what is uh the
plan or what is supposed to be the next
steps for the the
athena art assistant so right now we
have like many of those um
parts of our assistant but ultimately
what you want to do is to build an
application that has everything together
and uh we don't know yet that this is
going to be a website or a web app or
something of that sort of
app for the phone mobile app
but the idea is to have like a place
where uh both artists
non-technical people
and or ai people or technical people can
come and still get something out of it
so for the artists the idea is that they
can come they can bring their for
example they can contribute with their
artwork
for example if they want to share some
of their data of their
paintings or their poetry and so on and
then they can see they can see like how
they can fit the ai with this uh with
their work and see what it comes out of
this and this can maybe inspire them for
doing something new or something of that
sorts or can also help them to promote
their their work as well
uh for the non-technical people they can
still come and um
just enjoy seeing a new
style of art if you are interested in
art or if you're interested in
technology this is something that you
can still come and enjoy and so on and
if you're a technical person and you're
just like uh you want to you like to
program and so on and you want to come
and uh experience like some
different kinds of applications and
there's something that is too inspiring
and can help
the society as well like in terms of the
minorities and so on that's also a place
for you and that's our idea over here
uh of course like um
we would like to also especially for the
the people that are not so familiar with
the topic of uh
the lack of diversity in the arts or
world that we also have
part of our application that maybe put
some sort of information about that so
it's more educational as well
and you also want to have uh
like just keep improving and adding new
features for example then maybe you can
have some some uh speech feature that uh
you can have like a
athena actually talking to you such as
for example you have a alexa or siri or
something like that
um this is something that is doable for
sure uh it's just like for the sake of
time it was not possible for us to build
but yeah like there are many
applications that are possible and
many others that probably we didn't even
think through and then that's why it's
nice to have an open source project
because other people can contribute and
they can come with ideas and maybe they
don't know how to program that as well
but maybe they have the idea and someone
else has
has the ways to program that and that's
what is the beauty of open source
so uh just to finish i would like to
thank you all again for for your time
for being here tonight
and uh say that if you're interested in
contributing you can have a look into
our project like a little bit more about
it on that post this is where the
hackathon took place
uh you can also um
enter into our github it's not very
organized at the moment but we can go
over there and ideas also help us to
organize that as well
and uh the
sai factory hackathon uh they have
um lots of super interesting projects
that i really recommend you guys to
check i think there are like 40 projects
over there
i forgot to mention we we won the
special prize of that only had like a
couple of prizes we won the the special
prize um and uh yeah you can check other
of those projects over there i don't
know if they are open source or not but
they are still nice things to see
and if you're interested in contributing
with bringing more data with bringing
more techniques with
suggesting ideas or helping building the
application itself you are more than
welcome to
get in touch with me and uh we'll get in
touch with the other girls and hopefully
soon we're gonna have a page like for
the i wonder girls and then we can share
all those other things but uh yeah that
was it for
for me thank you so much
hey that was great
really nice really nice rosanna i really
like that
thanks
definitely thank you
so we start with the questions maybe we
already have
one and i think it had to do with um the
style transfer aspect of your
presentation steven asks
would this work as a photoshop filter
for a photo filter for sure like uh one
of our partners uh one of the girls
actually tried uh with her own pictures
just important presentation for
not sharing her own picture but uh it's
something that uh
that's the idea that we want to have
there's also like a work a little bit in
this user experience that uh for example
we have the
the style from from several female
artists and then the the users can come
there and take a selfie and just see how
it works
so that's the idea
thanks for the question
oh cool thank you too
other questions maybe
i have one
question
thinking on moving forward uh what do
you think it would be the best scenario
with what you were doing hosanna what
would be your vision for that for you
and the team
uh i would say that uh we still like uh
struggle a lot to get data so for um
i mean this is of course it was a data
centric project uh but
it's really hard to find like when you
really want us to talk about minorities
we managed to find data about women
artists but there's to the majority like
uh white females and so on so like a
diver like true diversity
is really hard and um and in this sense
it's nice to to actually connect to
to other artists and really come like to
the to the places where they are and uh
for example add new languages and uh we
were trying to connect uh to a lady from
uh from india that uh had her paintings
and so on so this might something that
we might add in the future so
but yeah like uh really having this true
um
diversity in our data
can i just ask how how long has it taken
to put all that wonderful stuff together
is it like a couple of years or yes i'm
sorry i'm the beginning of this so sorry
if you've already answered that and also
how many hours a week does an average
woman who's contributing to this project
kind of put it up obviously it doesn't
average to the same every week but what
sort of commitment is this
thanks uh for the question and um
wow
i think
since we started like uh
so we saw the hackathon and so on and we
decided to have the the
like a go for it and so on i think we uh
did this in about eight to ten weeks
but uh the reason why is because we were
following this approach of like we just
take whatever code is already out there
uh we managed to make it work
um
which we just changed the data but of
course i could spend a lot of time like
looking to the date and so on and i
would say that hours per week it's
difficult to say that we had a lot of
discussions a lot of brainstorming so at
least every week we would have one
one or one and a half hours
of discussion
plus some time you know like programming
so we were only five years so we were
six i don't know five we were trying to
really uh each one was taking part of
one of the
features of the assistant
but um ideally like of course if you
have more people working with you it
should be less
work but
thank you thank you
other remarks maybe
if not i have a question
uh i actually have
more than one but i start with uh
the first
um
you saw that actually you pick up from
this databases uh in terms of poetry and
also in terms of artworks like uh
paintings
the work of
female artists
have you run an analysis where you can
pull all these data and treat it as a
classification problem and then try to
guess the gender purely on
by feeding it very well
yeah we thought about doing that i mean
for
for for poetry
i mean it's tricky because we have a lot
of buyers with name and actually when i
was checking the data i actually noticed
that so it was like uh i don't know
someone has called my idea and i'm like
obviously this is a woman you know like
and
the majority of the case is true
and whenever you see uh unfortunately
this is a problem with our society like
whenever you see someone that has a name
that is just like initials or something
there is a very high chance that this is
a non-binary person
um and this is something that i've just
learned by tagging the data
in principle uh this is something you
can do
so you did the labeling
you yourself your thing did the label
okay okay we did but we didn't use any
any um
we didn't use any automated uh
classification so to say that's
that could be something that we do but
it would be biased uh because we are
presuming that i don't know peter is
male 1 yeah i thought that the artists
themselves like click like an option and
that's in the database and hence you
know it's kind of cool
but i don't know
okay
this is like really a massive
work like that sometimes people think
that the ai is something very fancy
we're just like telling the labeling
stuff
wow that's a lot of work yeah wow
and imdb also does not have a
more let's say uh objective entered by
the director themselves or herself yeah
one of our colleagues actually found
some already processed data set that
already had some of that so that was the
easier part but it's still like um
we are like kind of like a
[Music]
like the best way to do that would be
like checking ourselves and so on so um
but it's very hard to find the customer
sort of the data set that already has
a gender uh included
in it
another idea if there are no other
questions
well
yeah so one question there are in
literature because of course art goes
back to centuries
women writers often had to carry a man's
name in their publication
to be published
are there artists that
who were women in those days because
obviously more modern technology it's
not an issue so much now presumably um
but are the artists that have carry a
man's name but actually were women that
you're aware of
yeah there we had actually encountered
this problem and this is actually one of
the recommendations that we had to pitch
for our project uh to the to the how can
i say the people who are
evaluating them in the hackathon and
this is actually something that they
told us to be a bit careful with so
that's why the majority of the the works
that we have are actually modern
because uh then whenever you go to the
past and you kind of start having these
problems because you only see males but
that's not because they are only used
it's just as tricky so
thank you
other remarks
all right so
just a small remark that i had maybe you
tried to do the following but i don't
know if it makes sense in the first list
but but maybe it is
um have you tried let's say to do just
basic dimensionality reduction let's say
that you have the images of all the
artists and then do an unsupervised
clustering of sorts i mean you name it
[Music]
so then maybe like an in an unsupervised
way you would be able to
i don't know if that should be expected
but maybe you see some groupings
that have to do with this tentative uh
gender tags that you have generated so
that would be kind of a kind of
confirmatory way or not
but still informative either way i i i i
know but yeah for sure like i i can't
say that i work more in the poetry part
but uh one thing that i can tell you is
that uh
exactly like clustering would be able to
catch like those uh kind of trends that
uh groups follow so for example uh it's
very common that at least from the the
data that i saw
that uh transgender or non-binary poets
they usually talk about those
hard topics
whereas we don't see so many men talking
about them so if there is a poem uh
there is the has for example the lgbtq
uh topic there is a higher chance that
it was written by a non-binary person or
transgender person so this is something
that for sure like a clustering could
catch like it's a very good idea things
all right
other questions maybe or ideas or data
that you might know might be relevant
for these projects
please mention them
yeah we want to do something with music
as well like uh so if anyone has like
some data sets that are tagged or
something of the sort of music like
they're
very welcome to have them
are you interested also in
scientific publications because there is
a paper that actually addresses this
problem how many
sided work belongs to men or women given
the existing literature because there is
a bias inciting more
well
male scientist and i can send the link
actually you might find it over it's a
slight it has a slight different flavor
but it kind of belongs to this
yes
pressure
that's very interesting like i would be
very happy to see and as i said like uh
we and the girls like we are always
looking for this kind of projects like
we just to do something like a research
on our free time so this is actually a
very good idea
just paste it here maybe it is relevant
or maybe
not that relevant but in any case there
it is and there is a publication as well
just to see a bit more details
because it's not so well documented this
uh repo which is unfortunate but well
anyway that's that's amazing
sorry thanks
it's a shame that um the technology
isn't there yet but no that will be in
the future that you can't explore all
languages because just through the
english language there's there's
cultural implications for that and
historical reasons for that across the
world and
there may be other languages that even
if most of the writing is written by men
there may be different emotions and the
use of emotion in those language and how
they talk
more hard and difficult topics in the
that writing that this can't at the
moment access that
um exactly like i think we we of course
like uh because of the this is something
that we finished in september and i was
i was in brazil before and i was moving
here and so it was a bit of a chaotic
time for me but this is actually when i
when we were building this we were
thinking like uh we have now
tagged like our labeled data
and uh we of course didn't have much
time for analyzing because we were
finishing up stuff but
we have now uh this possibility to
actually look into this uh and as i said
unfortunately it's still very towards
like a very uh eurocentric uh you know
data sets that we have like in english
or about uh maybe white uh female
artists and so on but it's a start so
and maybe while building this we can
get connections and find more people and
so on so that's that's the idea
i have a last question
sure
what it helps on if you're because you
did this project in a hackathon and what
do you think are the success factors
when you are in a hackathon with a team
that can makes you win and really get
some great content out there
you know like i i think there are many
factors but uh one is like already
how can i say
there is this uh teamwork um
so we um some of the girls like i said
we were like our friends of friends so
it's not for example that i particularly
knew them before i knew a few of them
before but not all of them but uh there
is this kind of like a sisterhood this
um or i don't know brotherhood or
whatever gender but uh this uh team
spirit like uh of just like um
just working together uh and um and the
other thing that it it sounds silly but
uh it's very impressive uh
how much people start things and they
don't finish so
uh having this uh motivation like this
thing that like uh hey uh we have this
planning like how this week we want to
do this and next week we want to do that
and sometimes it doesn't work whether we
have a plan of what you want to do
it's very important um to just like from
the beginning to understand what is it
that we want to build and then just
really make a plan to throughout the
whole time that we have available so
thank you
thank you
more remarks
if not
maybe we can wrap up the first part and
have a really short break
and then
i think we will be back at uh five to
eight
okay so before that wait we have a link
to the music
thank you
no worries that would be really cool
and uh again i repeat if anyone wants to
participate in a project doesn't need to
be a woman but
the idea is that of course like we did
the first step but um
idea is to just put it out there and be
helpful for everyone so
if anyone wants to join uh help each
other too
is your um email either is it on the
meetup or on the github is that have we
contacted you
ah yes sorry let me just oh i just
closed my
so i can share my linkedin uh and i can
also share my email one second
we are also going to make some noise on
the pi data hamburg uh social media
account so we'll make sure hosanna can
be found out there
this is my i just shared in the chat
this is my linkedin and uh
i just remembered um i think was uh
alexander saying something about the uh
the wires in in uh
publications like uh i am actually like
i have a background research and once i
was in a conference and uh
um someone knew my work and father was i
was a guy because like i only had my
initials in my papers
so it is something that it indeed
happens
but yeah i just ran by my contacts and
i'll be happy to keep in touch
all right so yeah let's have this break
and thank rosanna again for this
really informative
talk
so
see you in a bit guys in 10 minutes to
be precise
see you in bed
thank you guys
so yeah um welcome back on the short
break um
we are going to
to the next talk and the title of the
talk is ipa parameter tune in with deep
learning
and the speaker today is um
tony getting the sony and
i'll just give a brief intro which is um
she's currently a researcher at the
university of lincoln
where she works on research solutions
that combine medical robotics through
both learning computer vision
um so she holds bs in computer science
and msc and robotics
so basically she's um she has supported
so many um organizations and
um recently she has supported code your
future
that's an organization that set up
weekend coding classes for refugees in
it the uk and other parts of europe a
fundamental core passion does not stop
at the idea of women in tech he dives
deeper in advocating on mediocrity
thereby propelling more women into
long-term leadership positions
after right quote it's interesting
it's
let your skills speak louder than your
agenda
so i would like to give the podium to
tony here
you're welcome
thank you so much oh i actually didn't
know that professionally right
i feel like i should have probably
needed one sentence
hello everyone thank you for joining the
live session
um so tonight i'm just uh hopefully
hopefully i'm not going to bore you
i'm just going to
give a presentation on hypothermia
in the planning
and then you're going to have like a
it doesn't have to be a hands-on session
and you can just follow me through the
code uh the organizer will send
the link to the record um
i'll just get started and share my
screen
and please confirm when you see my
screen
you see
i think i see myself
some others
okay
um so i'm talking about advanced singing
with me claiming
and uh hopefully like i said i'm going
to support you with this stuff
thank you so much
for that for presentation was so
insightful so let's get started
um why have a parameter
we know all of us here know that machine
learning ai data science the models and
everything around it is has made it
extremely powerful
um but we know that we struggle with the
issue of how to optimize the model for
example let's take a linear regression
problem where you're trying to optimize
the weight and the bias
to have a perfect fit of your
inputs to your outfits sometimes we
actually do not know uh it takes a lot
of
a lot of expertise a lot of working on
different problem sets data sets to
actually know the combination of
architectures and the layers that are
they are best for the kind of problem
and it's been saying that sometimes even
with the years of transforming sometimes
they fail on different um problem sets
and so it still remains a problem that
we have to optimize
uh because we have many variables that
we could change like configuration so
how do we really keep our science and
when we're training machine learning
models
so first of all let's establish
something um some
words and the parameter is different
from parameter uh when we talk about
parameters in machine learning those are
the
things that we constantly upgrade
updates like i said the weight on the
biases for example for a neural network
when you're training we have the back
propagation
where we are trying to train the weight
and buy and the model to give us the
perfect weight and biases that have a
perfect
mapping from a to b for example
and the one that we do not change during
the
during our training are called the
iphone parameters these remain constant
all through the period of the training
so
think of other parameters as
configuration settings where you're
trying to find the perfect fit for your
program like i mentioned earlier this
time other parameters do do always have
to change depending on the kind of
problem or the kind of solution you're
trying to build or the kind of data sets
that you even have um
it's not a
one-size-fits-all um kind of
configuration for different purposes and
sometimes
you will find out that this particular
configuration works for this problem set
and if you bring it even to a similar
problem set you'll find out that you may
even perform worse
[Music]
so for example uh some of the other
parameters we uh
though that we can we are used to all i
believe most of us are familiar with
aligning with the batch size the talks
uh which is like you know when you train
on an impulse by batch and then the
optimizers different we have the same
kind of optimizer the other optimizer
or the gradient descent and all of those
and then you have different
regularization techniques and drop outs
regularization technique or for example
you have your l1 or l2 sometimes you
even combine both so how do we really
know which is perfect for any problem
set and how do we reduce our time of
trying to configure things
i would also like to say that we may
have seen in escalante that in escalant
we have
uh some search uh
models that are all set uh search
libraries that have been built within
sklen but
one there there is a difference between
how the world process what we're going
to see today because i i am as a strong
opinion with my experience that
excellence does not really uh shine
when it comes to how you should know the
how many things that should go into your
cnn layer or how many people should go
into your masculine layer and all of
those and we are going to be looking at
um two libraries
and so there is a all combination of
uh different parameters and like i said
it's
really kind of it's not something that
we can do manually and so we have
different search algorithms that have
been deal with the two languages that
we're going to look at to do tonight and
uh we will see how all of them um are
effective and can
scale uh the time that we spend in
either parameter team
so the two libraries are the parastuna
and the optima
um for this uh i have decided so i
actually changed this last means to the
event because i was going to use a text
data set and also exclusive set so
depending the same is actually the text
data well i decided to use the
uh other dataset that i have which is a
fish classification data set so we have
different french images and we want to
classify it to be a proper class so
we're going to look at how we can use
skeleton library to do this as the name
implied you must have guessed that this
works with keras
and otuna um
works with uh by touch it works with
keras as well so all of these libraries
have their
downsides and they are upside they have
where they shine better than the other
and we are also going to see that as we
go through the
code that i have
um i believe obinna has shared the link
to the google drive
so but if you don't have it this is it
it's just literally
hyper to me so you can just type that
and you are going to find
the order to save those the one for the
fish transparation and the one for
defending transmutation so are there any
questions before we go into the amazon
session
i'm just going to
wait for that's why i switch
my
screen
any questions because i can look at the
chat
but i'm hoping that um
so i'm just going to minimize this and
we'll continue
so this is um the personal
uh
example
and like i said i'm going to use this
with a
fish classification if you want to look
at the text classification that i did
it's also on that link feel free to look
at that after the after this session
tonight
but this the one way we can add is the
fish classification where we're gonna
have an image just a simple task the
purpose of this session is really not to
go into a problem that is you know
expensive or complex it's just to show
us how we can adapt whatever uh we speak
tonight to any of our architecture for
any problem that we're trying to solve
for any machine learning learning model
we're trying to do
so and the first thing we want to do is
this i'm not going to be running um this
for life
and this is because i found out that it
takes a lot of time as you know like
when you're training even though the
wrong time isn't cpu
i found that like it takes a lot of time
to train um i could have decided to
reduce the
the data size for this but i thought it
was um i should not alter the entire
code base so that even after the class
uh you can run by yourself and see the
performance of things like this so the
first thing is to install canvas tuner
and this is the library uh depending on
whatever environment you're vision and
after running that um
we can always import the necessary
um
libraries that we need these are this
i'm just i'm going to skip a lot of
things because i'm sure like
some of us are looking to uh declining
and some of the things that we have to
say this is just important the essential
libraries that are needed for what we're
about to do
so
and then here we are i'm reporting the
random search
um i'm also going to talk about the
different search approach that we had in
paris to now uh i'm just going to talk
about one or two of it uh not dwell on
too much on the different uh the
different ways or how all of this such
algorithm works i
i'll leave that to everyone to there are
a lot of resources that explain all of
these such algorithms
and then here i'm just uh
[Music]
to look at the image while i just um
looking at the
image uh path and the level for that
image
and here is
uh piloting
some examples of the
of some of the classification that you
have so here we have the customer cloud
and what it looks like and we just want
to do the very simple
cnn network that
takes the image and is able to give us
the class that it belongs to and for
this um data set i have actually bought
you from cabo
and um babysit so if you go to cargo um
you're going to find but even in the in
the link all of the app already
downloaded folded sets in there
so uh we have four classes of um fish
that we are using for this um
tutorial
and we have um the black scratch like
i'm actually not familiar with some of
these
facial dialogues i love seafood
but this we are just doing four classes
here
and that's the one i'm just doing here
is finding out um how many pounds or
they're just making sure that i have a
balanced data set uh in in the old in
the old training and so that is what i'm
doing here so i have 200 images for each
of the sample or each of the class that
i have
um here
and here it's just uh this is a function
from estimate
where we are training village i'm trying
to split into my train and test so what
i forced to do here was split into the
training test and then in the second
line i'm splitting the game based on
just the chain so i'm trying to get the
train and validation from here just to
have a balanced uh you know test sets
validation sets and training sets
and here uh it's just
uh printing the sheets all of these do
not really matter because anyone that
test sets more than the validation we
found the switched and i said today's
focus is really not about classifying a
fish it's just showing us how can we
apply at the parameters and see this
problem set of classifying definition
and yes this is just also loading it
into the image data generator for our
model i'm also going to not talk too
much on this uh this is also a function
from paras to actually um
book on the data set and prepare like
the data processing uh
process
to
underwater the model when it's time to
train
so
let's get started uh this is where the
main thing is happening
so for cares tonight
there are things that you can change
there
and first of all a disclaimer
these two libraries none of them
shows you how many layers should you
have in your network so the model
hopefully probably in the future they
are going to update versions where
the model can tell you you know here you
should have just four layers of
um from 2d and there or three layers or
two layers however what they do is that
when you prepare your architecture
they tell you you are able to set for
example in your home 2d layer you have
many variables there you have your
filters you have your panel size and you
can even put your regularization method
and all of those
what
the layer and the character does is
allow you to change um the units which
is the papers that you know
and
the first thing you want to do is just
declare a function and pass in this hp
this hp is like the kerastana objects so
it's like passing the object as a
pyramid like a class of its own you pass
it into the function it can be any name
that we want of course and then you
start
declaring
your your layers so for example i'm not
using the functional um api i'm just
using the sequential
way of stacking the layers and in this
model what i just want is
the first um contouring layer
followed by max pulling cd this is this
has nothing to do with um
it's just a basic and there's no
intention to
come up with these layers and then after
that i want to have four layers of
concealer
followed by each of each of the layers
you've been followed by a max fully cd
and then i'm just flattening out the
layer or whatever output i've gotten up
to here and then i pass um three
dense layers or let me say four for
these layers where the last one is
actually
uh what gives me the output ions because
i'm using the soft marks
that gives me the probabilities of it in
the particular class of fish and of
course the fall here has to be constant
because you know you have those four
classes so i'm going to go back here so
here is the normal um that we used to
when we play sequential layer
and in the contour d layer
you can have um
you start the same the object that i
mentioned earlier we start with that and
there are different um
data types that we can call on this
object the first one the most popular
one is the games
value because most of the time when
you're changing is actually an integer
um value so for the filters for example
you can then set a minimum value
so
the normal way that would have gone
about this is probably just cooking two
five c so or one two eight you know
uh you can look at an architecture
online and just get
replicated or sometimes just do an
admission study
um of you know combination of players
but what um this other parameter would
do is that you can set a minimum value
for your filter
and then you set the maximum value for
the future and the maximum i want you to
go is 256
and then you know you can steps and sets
the space so this step is basically um
the values that is harder from the
initial up to when you get to 2 56 so
it's like a and x is uh
lesser or not greater
than or equal to 64 but is lesser than
and because it sits with the steps of
you getting two
i hope i was clearing that so for
example when our search began we started
64 and then 64 plus 32 will give us 96
96 32 and all that continues in research
um
until we get to five six you can also do
the same with the
panel size but here i've just set it to
three by three
and then i've just made all that things
constant so that it doesn't look too
complex but
every time you have a value than an
integer you can always set the uh
integrator hp.value
if we actually print um
the
methods that we can call on the hp we'll
actually find a very range of different
values or data types and that that is
associated with that object and it
depends on whatever they are that we
want to apply the objects uh like we
want to do the attack parameters search
uh will determine what's in the type of
interviews
and here i'm just doing a basic um
in there that we have something that is
just um you can also join our
normal
um
training and what i have done here is
just having a for loop
um instead of i could decide to remove
this folder for example
and repeat
these two um
layers the console the and the maximum
tv that i have here but this is also
another way where you don't have to keep
um stacks of the same type of layers and
you can always um just like the for loop
where you passing the range and the
hp dot
and then you set it as anywhere yes and
you're saying okay i want it to be
um
three layers because we know that it's
range it stops at industry of course and
um
and then here we are setting with the i
value that is saying when that's one two
three and all that and the same thing we
did
but i hope i'm not going too fast until
i feel like i'm going to pass no not at
all okay thank you
so
so
where we have the minimum value 32 here
and also the maximum is 56 you see that
it's different from what i have here
where i'm saying start at 64. and of
course the 32 can also you know
understand this too
because i like the number
um that is incremented until you get to
two practices so what happens in the
search when it begins to search and
starts
and
it's
when you go to when it goes to this
follow it starts from the very basic and
then it's doing like a you see like as a
combination of the fermentation kind of
mathematics search where you're
combining different values based on this
configuration and
we are also going to get to the parts
where uh
when we define
the
the at the the metric that we want to
use for the model to know that
i'm actually performing well with this
set of values
so um so that is that about this for
loop where for each layer just for each
art item i'm just adding the call to the
layer and the maximum
layer
and after that i'm just flattening out
before it goes into the dense layer and
in the dense layer as well the same
thing that we've done uh you can do that
here it's just
meaning the same way we will name the
particular layer for a regular uh
network that we're trying to build
and
then we set the activation function so
one of the setback
of kerastina is that it doesn't allow
you to um play around with the
activation layer actually this is
something that uh i'm also looking into
the game we should be able to update
that soon
but um for now i found out like they
they don't
but in terms of the filters and videos
for some layers then that is that's
available so
excuse me we have this um
dance mirrors
and uh you know i've just said the
minimum value i've done basically the
same thing that i've done in the
previous videos i'm doing it here
and
at the end of the day i'm just
doing the final outputs where i am
now setting um the last layer prediction
to before
based on the number of classification
you want to do
and then you're just like compiling the
model that you would always do
um one other thing that's
kerastroma allows you to explain is the
learning rates of your choosing
and
optimizer so here i'm just using the
other
optimizer you can use the s3d and the
other types that you have
and i'm setting like the values that are
here so here you cannot put it as uh
from here to here you can only put it as
a list of choices or a list of values
that you want to want to um
assign so here you can see that we are
using choice because uh
the reason why we are using choices
because online here where when we use
things we give it minimum and the
maximum range and the steps it should
take between the ranges here we just
choice
um
you have to fill in um a list of values
for this particular
um
for this particular value that we're
trying to see
and also the loss is also something that
the emergency
and
how you can have a change
and then i'm just setting the metrics as
an accuracy and determining the model
um so like i said i'm going to just
briefly mention so
all the characters now you have the
random search strategy which is just
random um there's no strategy about
research just you know randomly fixed
value with the steps and all that and
based on the metric that you have said
it tells you the best strategy
um but uh we have the bioshell
optimization if you click this link to
link to the explanation of kitchen thing
they also have the excellent i'm
actually not uh to be honest i'm not
playing around all of these um such
strategies i usually just
go for the random um search because it
seems to be working for
most of the time when i when i try it's
in my own at work or when i'm trying to
do something but the hyperbag is uh
kind of a higher step than random search
because it's first of all start random
um
it random something of the upper
parameters in research things
and after a particular let's say um on
the iterations
from the metric it's able to get
feedback and then it eradicates like the
ones that are believing badly like in
the parameters that they believe in um
badly so we discuss them and then the
ones that are good it's
run another kind of attraction on each
again so it's like a binary um let's say
finally
but yeah i wanted to say binary status
maybe not binary set but it keeps
running and keeps cutting it um by half
but then it gets to you know
uh one model that stands out of
everything so in that way there's less
resources that's being used that it
takes less of time because it's not just
random it's strategic about how it's
cutting off some of the such things that
are not meaningful to or that are not um
working well for the program that we're
trying to solve
so given that we have established a
function here and we are trying to build
a search space
so the next thing is to use one of these
strategy
so you can use the random search
if i click this floor
up you can see that this random stage is
not from escalant it's from kerastina
itself
and
let's go all the way back
right here that's what i'm using here
but you can try the virus and
optimization behind the band you can see
all of them if you look at the link on
my top
my bottom left you see that um as i'm
highlighting it's pointing to the link
that goes to all of the documentation of
how these
um search strategies work
and then we just pass in the class
number which is basically the function
that we have declared here
so getting there we also put our
objective our objective is what we're
trying to
maximize
and then we also put a maximum trial
saying i want to suggest five times so
that means that it may not be exhaust
all of the such space that we have
because we're just doing five times
random um search and this is just uh
where i'm seeing the model
that this isn't something that's
significant
so this is actually where
we now do research stage and
search
space
summary so it just returns um
it returns a summary of
the search that we have declared in this
function
so if we take a little quick look at
that
it's can you tell me how many minutes do
i have many more minutes
yeah you have about um let's say
15 minutes they're about
okay
how child specifically moves so um this
is uh what this does is just give a
summary of um only it's summary of the
description about such
for example the following for cnn means
it tells us the minimum value is 64 the
maximum is 256 and
um the state is 62 and the enemy's
easing instead of something so that's
just what this is about
and this is where the training actually
takes me so i've just done five reports
and even the five of them
take a lot of time
because yes we are searching so
uh it takes some time and this is like
when you do your feet and your
your passing in your data and your
efforts and your validation data and
then it runs that's um
the maximum trial of the sexually doing
like a combination permutation kind of
thing and then it keeps actually
updating you on the best uh validation
accuracy so it's saying okay so far what
we have is this so we can see that 60
of the validation sets is correct with
the accuracy that you're using
and then um after it shrinks
so now it's the
object we're using then we can do a
result summary and just tells you like
for each
um
summary that you have tried which is
five in that case because it is four and
this one is basically accuracy
and you see that same always is actually
the very first search that i knew that
gave me the best result if you compare
it to this um i would say that i have
tried this with strategy ebooks and i
was able to get like uh
something
um
but uh
when i was trying to see how i could
quickly
um you know try to stand it on like run
during the process
it was taking more time
and then
after that i would get the best
it's just during into another campus
and it's actually the reason why i'm
doing no model because
one and then picking the first one is
because
um in the get best models and you have
to set like how many the top
models that can do it that way because
it's actually put all of the models it
saves like the model in the memory for
each of the search and then arranges it
according to how the validation score
and the nature has performed so this is
just going to become the very first one
at the top
and when we get the model we can then
just the same way we'll predict and this
is just the add max is for me to get the
arrows
the right prediction and then this is
this part is just um
getting the predictions and getting the
labels from the particular
tests and sets that i'm using
and then under the
accuracy here like i said this is slow
um but when i tried to change the focus
it was able to
tell me the
word i think it was about 80.
so to wrap this up
um how do you know
we don't always have to search every
time so once we get our best model it's
actually going to tell us the
combination like this is for example the
units one the right value was 64. for my
density needs the right volume was um
2x8 so it tells us a breakdown of the
right units that give the each for each
of the trials i gave this call and we
can just then use that to extract and
come up with our architecture when we
are now you know hard coding the values
into it
so this is how kerastana works um are
there any questions before i quickly
move to optional
hopefully i will run out of time with
that
one
all right so for the two optional
the otuna is
another library for either parameter to
me the advantage of the optional is that
it works with
keras and what's up as well although i
am not very familiar with fine touch uh
but uh
with optima or like keras which is just
based on tensorflow you know keras
optional can be used to
so that's one of the advantages that i
see
now
and uh this is actually the installation
of scarce
and
we can
combine um
the optima so in this case
the octane does not work by itself
if you so this is where i'm just
importing it
um but optila does not work by itself
without this obscuras if you want to use
optional with optical ass um if you want
to use optimum with terrace then you
have to um
also import this obscura so that is the
one that i installed here
and you can also install and the option
with you please as well
so you don't have to install um you know
you don't you don't have to
install just optional you have to
actually install obscuras as well
because um optional cannot actually work
by itself without the oxygen
as well
so um i'm just going to skip all of this
because we've seen that in the previous
slides
um we've seen all of this and this is
where we are coming to
um
for this um case uh we just start with a
name for our function and we call the
upstairs class
this is uh
you can't make this any other thing this
is like a repeating function where when
you pass in the trial object it's it's
able to identify this as you
wanting to add the pattern with proxima
and hot squares
and the same way of what we are done
when we are using the model um
where we are using these questions what
i'm going to do here as well
but in this case the advantage that
optional juicy as you see is that
you can actually
put the kind of activation layer so
these are just the major little
difference between optima and parasana
and
for each
value the same way we have better types
in where we have each students in which
we have choice in keras
here when you pass in the object trial
we
also
this service category is like the data
type so for your filters um
you can't do the steps
or like in paris where you can put the
minimum and the maximum range
um with uh filters i actually tried to
do it because you see that there's
suggestions i try to do it with you guys
but i saw that you wanted a category
call but i think that's just how the the
autos or the
people who gives it up
um
uh maybe to walk so
the filter is actually categorical when
you're passing values
this time around you have to just pass
in your own random values
and then
um for the kind of size they allow you
to use steps where you can save it to
two by two
then
three by three with the step of one and
then four by four and so on and the
strides as well
you can also use things here i think
this steps because you just have one and
two so that's why but if you maybe i
want to do a cycle one to five you can
pass in your step center
for the activation is also the
categorical
so
in the activation function uh you can
pass in um
more than one or like terra so now where
is just one for now and then your input
shape which is basic
and then i'm adding the maximum layer
right here you have the range as well
where i'm adding
four layers and i'm not going to repeat
this it's just basically this um except
that it's really following where i'm
creating areas
um of this concluding they are the
masters here and i'm just flattening
like that on the last one
and then followed by these things layers
where i'm also
turning the inks
somebody does they allow you to use
their eights
and then you can pass in the values and
the steps and then the activation
function you want to try with the reload
or the email and so on and so forth it's
because my time is running open so
forgive me if i'm trying to rush through
this
and uh and then again it's just a drop
out and it's just hardcoded
and then in this density i'm just
repeating the same thing
and
the activation function they understand
the same thing that you're saying
another set so one setback is optional
is that when you are confining online
comparison now where we could say okay
and the other optimizer is what i'm
using and i want to try different
learning weights because i'm still here
so where you can try different learning
weights
in the optimum you cannot try and defend
any weight you just have to put whatever
thing is put
and then the loss and the metrics can be
done
and inside the same function we are
going to fix and passing the data the
validation
and then the callbacks that he
wants this is just for
this is not necessary but again
you know the messages that have been
printed
and
we returned this
so once logging in let's remember study
name is a variable then created here
that
is pointing to the observance class
which is uh basically returning um
when it does research it becomes the
best trial uh you know the best
research
and then after that we do an optimize
this optimizes like the fits in
in
what we have with the normal models and
it's like defeats and then we pass in
the function objective and here i'm
doing in trials and
um i'm just putting a timeout just in
case i'm
taking so much time and things like that
and then how do we know the best trial
we just did a study name
parameter so excuse me
because again you can now extend this
take it out of the
[Music]
out of the
[Music]
how that's architecture fits to the
problem we're trying to solve
and here is just
me also trying to
get the value for the predictions that's
that we have the
and then understands the trigger
policies called the test against the
prediction and this is principle yes
this is very forwards i also changed it
by the folks so there is really not
much um existation of
existing search parents to use improved
values um but when i
compared the result of the restaurant on
ottoman i actually found out that
sarasota has
a greater story search than krishna
so um i have also included here if you
want to join this uh the project within
fire touch i want to try um
um i have included some names here and
that's that's about how you can use
optimal expiration
and uh this takes me to the end
of this talk
i hope you find it useful and i hope it
will help you save more time when you
are i'm trying to come up with a perfect
architecture for your progresses
thank you for
joining
um
the
paris one took about nine minutes to run
it looked is that have i got that right
and what was the time did they run along
a similar level of time or
no when it comes to the
uh keras i found that it was slower but
the optima was actually faster
okay
yeah and the the kerosene produced about
six um
values
and the first one turned out to be the
most um accurate in its predictions
did the opportunity produce one at the
bottom there yes this one right where
you're talking about this part
yeah
yes the optima so that is what yeah i
forgot to mention that that is also one
of the setbacks that i saw with the
optimum because it just returns like
these values where you don't actually
even know like okay which of my network
should i fix
right this this values but the tuna
actually tells you for each one for each
layer which is the perfect condemnation
yes
so they have like i said they have like
setbacks and you know advantages about
each other but i believe like optimal
was just released this year from right
so i believe there are some actuations
that is already going on to update what
we're currently have
okay
thank you
for the question
i need another one
any more questions
the capacitor gpu capacity was it um
was it sort of small and easy or
affordable how much
how much
so
yes yes thank you for that question i
was going to mention that this should be
an option where
that comes when you've tried maybe your
own you know basic architecture because
search is something that takes time
it's it takes time because you're trying
to like you have these all things shown
at you and you're trying to find a
perfect fit so i would say like
in the lab for example
we have the resources but when it comes
to like maybe pet project or site
project i don't usually recommend a
parameter even though i know it's good
because the the resources that you need
um to find the perfect search can
sometimes be on you know
like packaged and even but i find that
that with the i use the google collab
and i used it on the cpu i found that
like with the 28 box and
with the old wild search that i did it
was actually it took about two hours
um for i'll see an average for both of
them about maybe two and a half
so it's still all dependent on the how
large your data set is and unlikely i've
expanded your search
i hope that's yeah it's not a yeah i
don't think it's kind of straightforward
and science it does depend on you know
what you're trying to do
and finally is the the fish data set is
that open are they an open date for
anybody to use okay yes yes it's
actually improving the data site is
downloading the room i'm going to add a
couple uh link and i'll be still
pull up and i'm going to be probably
it's actually i'm targeting
any other questions
hopefully i have not bought you
[Music]
questions or remarks or whatever
oh yes i remember if you want to try any
of this with text
data
it's also there is a tutorial in the
simulink it's just that i couldn't cover
that as well um you know sometimes we
use different for different energy tasks
so
you you can find the dataset for that
and i think they are called uh it's kind
of faster straightforward
as well
i have a question
okay let's say i'm let's say i'm no data
scientist and i want to start figuring
out about all of this that we're doing
how can i start what is your career
advice
i would say don't start with this
don't start reading
please don't
if you're starting out no i have a
parameter is not the first thing you
should be doing
just go the normal way and then when you
are fully convinced that you understand
the
basic layers and everything then you can
try it
okay okay now to be serious yes i don't
think this is something that it's it's
uh i see it as a tool for someone who is
already you know have some familiarity
with um machine learning models and
different science
so no don't start this host
just one dress just to make sure you
know like it's just you know like just
just asking you know
asking for a friend
okay don't stop sharing my spring now
here we go
any more questions of our
remarks
there is a question in the chat
all right so it says what thank you for
the nice presentation what
considerations should we consider if we
run the project with penguins data set
um
okay thank you for the question
the penguin that said is uh i because
it's it starts data like i said so
um the
pre-processing
for text data is definitely different
from way of purchasing um image 50 sets
so the slice thing that you can look at
is of let me see that is that has
changed with the
with the text with the penguin that he
said is that i have done some
pre-processing of congrats in the words
of course to vectors because um you know
when you're training you need to
um the
models when you speak numbers and not
words per se so the preprocessing is
just what is a bit different um from the
penguins
because i have to process it into
vectors that then pass into the
musical models
so i think i think
okay i hope that was it before
thank you
[Laughter]
okay
i guess not
so
let me just put the final slide here
before i stop the recording
and then we can just
maybe have about two minutes
so thanks everyone for joining us if you
want you can follow us at pi data
hamburg
the